[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition en direct
sur tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 9
février voici les titres et dans
l'actualité forcément du foot avec la
rencontre entre le fc versailles et
bergerac en quart de finale de coupe de
france un record historique pour le club
versailles et coup d'envoi à 18h30
depuis le stade de périgueux les enjeux
et l'ambiance sur place dans ce journal
un match à suivre également sur écran
géant à versailles le jeu ap city en
compétition pour l'as d'or de meilleur
jeu de l'année un jeu de cartes éditées
par cocktail games à versailles objectif
battre une bulle heureuse nous sommes
allés à découvrir le concept et puis le
salon de l'agriculture ouvrira ses
portes le 26 février en attendant ce
rendez vous devenu incontournable dans
le domaine nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de producteurs yvelinois qui
participe au salon est découverte de la
maison paul mieux pour ce premier volet
[Musique]
et c'est le jour j pour le fc versailles
l'équipe affronte bergerac pour les
quarts de finale de coupe de france un
parcours historique et coup d'envoi ce
soir à 18h30 les deux clubs se
rencontrent au stade francis rongiéras
de périgueux en dordogne un match
attendu justement de nos journalistes
ont fait le déplacement en bus avec les
joueurs et les supporters grégory canal
est nickel et demi d'euros seront avec
nous en duplex depuis le stade nous
retrouvons également nicolas landry à
versailles où un écran géant a été
installé pour suivre ce match bixente
mais rien santisteva ne vous êtes avec
nous pendant toute la durée de
l'émission et puis jean-pierre meurillon
vous êtes notre invité ce soir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes avec nous par
téléphone je le précise vous êtes le
président du district deuxième ligne de
football
on avait posé la question aux yvelinois
tous s'accordaient à dire qu'il ait
souhaité voir le club versailles et
affronter une grosse équipe finalement
le tirage au sort en a décidé autrement
et ils sont opposés les joueurs à
bergerac une équipe
que de même donc de même niveau
justement donne mauvaise nouvelle selon
vous
on a écouté
de toute façon
de toute façon pour la pour le club
quelques toiles ordinaire annuelle
jamais
je voudrais simplement souligné que
pour les demi finales ce sera la
quatrième fois en presque trente ans on
club
et ce serait extraordinaire
justement vous bixente vous avez
rencontrées elles les joueurs dans quel
état d'esprit était utile au moment du
tirage pour les joueurs forcément c'est
un bon tirage en termes sportifs justin
pour accéder aux demi finales bergerac
c'est l'autre petit poucet c'est ce
match et le duel entre deux équipes qui
ont les mêmes armes mais quand on est un
club un joueur amateur de nationale 2
forcément on veut se frotter aux plus
gros le capitaine mal durant de jeu
vignes et en parler en lui c'était
vraiment marseille nice ou encore monaco
qui était en lice qui voulait tirer pour
affronter les grandes équipes et dans
des grands stades et justement à
jean-pierre nous rions quels sont les
enjeux ce soir pour le match
alors que l'enjeu c'est de réussir une
performance
versailles a une chance sur deux et
j'espère que la victoire tombera de ce
côté là
aucun club de nationale 2 à 1 en
demi-finale ça ça n'arrive quasiment
jamais ce serait une performance
extraordinaire
comme mon père me reloaded le disais
allez les clubs de nationale 2 en quarts
de finale il y en a eu que quatre il ya
calais en 2000 qui ramène en finale on a
aussi montceau les mines en 2007
quevilly en 2010 et enfin plus récemment
le club de rumigny vallières l'année
dernière en 2021
j'en perds c'est le premier quart de
finale de coupe de france d'un club
yvelinois hors paris saint-germain
pourtant les yvelines c'est un
département de football avec un vivier
réputé en termes de formation notamment
c'était une année une anomalie le fait
que qu'aucun club n'a réussi à se hisser
ainsi un tel stade de la compétition
juste ici
ben oui je pense qu au cp une anomalie
oui mais c'est bien mais ceci étant dit
le nombre de clubs qui sont encore
qualifiés à ce jour il est très
important c'est encore encore une fois
c'est exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel
j'ai pas de mots je voudrais juste
souligner
souligné que dans le club de rumilly
l'année dans l'année dernière qui a
battu toulouse il y avait le gardien de
versailles qui joue à versailles et qui
va jouer ce soir
delaunay le gardien du coup de
versailles exactement cette précision à
bixente qu'est ce qui a payé selon vous
pour la montée directe est ce que c'est
c'est l'investissement à l'arrivée du
nouveau directeur général du club jean
luc arribart et qu'est ce qui a permis
cette montée pour l'équipe
je pense que le club ce qu'il souhaite
le directeur général a fait savoir est
ce qu'ils valent fait monter dans leur
division supérieure
mais par contre on sait difficile
d'empêcher les joueurs de faire des
performances et de gagner les matches ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est qu'après
après le match de ce soir quoi qu'il
arrive en tout état de cause que le club
se préoccupe de son classement qui
actuellement est favorable et de son
classement championnat et ça va
commencer dès dimanche à poissy et cette
rencontre ça représente quoi peut-être
en terme financier pour un club amateur
comme versailles
enfin je pense que c'est là c'est la la
comment puis je vous dire fait savez ça
véhicule une image qui démontre que le
club est un grand club entre guillemets
et que à versailles on peut aussi faire
du foot quoi c'est encore une fois ça va
être le club véhicule son équipe
véhicule une image qui est extrêmement
positif pour lui mais aussi extrêmement
positive pour le foot si faire vous
allez regarder le match j'imagine un
jean-pierre nous rions we will je vais
regarder le match vous tout à fait tout
à fait merci vous pouvez d'avoir été
avec moi je l'appelle vous êtes le
président du district des yvelines de
football bon mètre
à bixente les joueurs versailles et son
train de marquer l'histoire on disait
avec jean pierre moriau l'histoire du
club et pourquoi ils sont arrivés en
quarts de finale quoi qu'il arrive ce
soir finalement c'est une victoire c'est
une victoire pour le club forcément me
qualifiant en parallèle cette directeur
de la communication de versailles il m'a
confié que médiatiquement c'est
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour le
club ils vont essayer de surfer là
dessus et est d'autant plus que leur
objectif principal vous l'avez rappelé
les gens permet on l'a rappelé c'est le
championnat et l'accession la troisième
division de la nationale ça c'est un
objectif pour lequel ils sont encore en
lice et s'ils y arrivent en fin de
saison ça sera forcément une saison en
or pour lequel ils ont leur chance pour
cet objectif ils sont bien partis à des
concurrents il reste encore des matchs
alors on ne peut pas se positionner
forcément c'est les favoris puisqu'ils
sont en tête mais voilà la saison n'est
pas finie je vous le disais en titre
tout à l'heure deux de nos journalistes
ont fait le déplacement en bus avec les
supporters et les joueurs mickaël hay et
demi d'euros et gregory k l'année vous
êtes grégory canal et vous êtes présent
et vous êtes arrivé au stade comment ça
s'est passé comment est l'ambiance à
quelques minutes du coup d'envoi
ça a été un véritable périple à justin
fait partie avec grégory très tôt ce
matin on a pris le bus à versailles au
stade mobo vous alentours de 9h30 9h45
déjà il y avait une grosse ambiance avec
56 à supporters survoltés des chants des
gens inventent est aussi un point lors
d'un périple jusqu'à midi on était dans
le bus on est descendus on l'a branché à
un petit peu une demi-heure en seulement
parce que le taux j'étais quand même
assez loin il fallait qu'on atteigne
périgueux je dis oui non pas leur jeu
rac en de m'atteindre peyridieux et du
coup ça arrêté pendant environ une demi
heure on a repris le chemin on va payer
si cher ça s'est très bien passé il n'y
a pas eu de cesse dans l'après-midi en
tout chaque fois ils ont ils ont voulu
chanter dans dans le bus et ensuite est
arrivé à la pancarte qu'on l'a vu un
martyr périgueux là forcément les
supporters étaient survoltés les
policiers nous ont escortés fisea
jusqu'au stade de périgueux yahoo a
chuté à la rencontre on vient tout juste
d'arriver à ses fins a été un peu un peu
précipité pour se connecter à ce soir on
vient d'arriver il ya déjà beaucoup de
supporters 56 à supporter à versailles
et sur le papier mais bon chez moi dans
le stade et le match va débuter dans
quelques instants on va justement
revenir sur les enjeux avec
donc dans quelques minutes ouais les
enjeux du match passait avant tout cas
une place ou deux finales deux derniers
kilari ses coûts de façon il n'aurait
scorer tient seul match ou versailles et
pour atteindre la finale qui se
disputera au stade de france et face à
versailles un gros de nationale 2 on
peut le qualifier de jumeaux de
versailles c'est mary que c'est bergerac
c'est cette amérique et on a tendance
aussi à s'envoyer mais c'est en tout cas
bergerac leader
versailles et ils n'ont pas perdu à
l'équerré depuis septembre donc c'est
une équipe à battre et en plus dans
cette de france ils ont déjà éliminé des
gros il ya des gros et bien afficher sur
l'un des terrains de chasse est éliminé
en 32e de finale clubs de ligue 1 il y à
créteil
éliminé en seizièmes me
suis fait hier en 8e de finale donc face
à saint-etienne les victoires 3-0 le
leader de nationale 2 qui a battu le la
lanterne rouge de ligue 1 et donc on a
la composition officielle dé versailles
et une une équipe qui ne change pas pas
trop par rapport aux huitièmes de finale
et cette victoire face à toulouse on
garde une équipe qui gagne garde une
équipe qu'il ya une delaunay dans les
buts et à tous deux jeux dignes et en
défense avec donc le brassard de
capitaine à quezon également sur cette
défense à trois lignes de quatre au
milieu de terrain avec traoré virac est
bien présent lui qui a été expulsé alors
vu match face à toulouse et qui a purgé
sa suspension lors d'un match de
championnat diarrassouba kamba juste
devant en numéro 10 michel et il sera
donc derrière les deux attaquants silva
et djoko choco le buteur on le rappelle
la presse à toulouse les dix coup
d'envoi à 18h30 et se dispute ici à
périgueux parce que le stade de bergerac
n'est pas homologué on a obtenu une
dérogation pour jouer dans ce stade de
rugby et le coup d'envoi est à 18 ans
alors michael d'habitude on est
journaliste on se mouille pas mais là on
est benoît avant tout et on va montrer
les petits bruits allaient versailles
justin tu as beau cadeau store gros
cadeau et il semble qu'on a même une
image de ce matin dans le bus en tout
cas du déplacement
là-bas encore l'image bon c'est pas
grave on a pas on n'a pas l'ambiance du
bus on la passera peut-être tout à
l'heure
c'est je crois mais calais gros gorille
dites-moi est-ce que les supporters
encore on va encore de la voix dans le
stade puisqu'on les a entendu crier nous
on l'a suivie sur les réseaux sociaux
ils ont pris toute la journée
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a perdu à faire de la
communication avec nos journalistes
c'est pas grave à bixente vous à quel
joueur vous allez suivent de près ce
soir oui je voulais revenir justement
sur ce que grégory a dit le titulaire
c'est capita fans djoko c'est le buteur
commis lundi contre toulouse c'est le
buteur contre sarre union c'est un peu
une surprise puisque
le christopher iba il autre attaquant
normalement il est sur la composition
titulaire aussi
vers ce à quoi qu'il arrive les
caractéristiques du club sait que c'est
une équipe très soudée c'est le
collectif qui prime on les avait vus par
exemple contre la roche vendée en 16e de
finale avec la victoire 4 0 c'est une
équipe efficace et quand elle veut ne
pas prendre de but elle ne prend pas de
but en général en tout cas on dit merci
à grégory canalini calais et demi
d'euros et j'espère qu'ils passeront un
bon match tous les deux sur place en
tout cas dans les commerçants de
versailles certaines boutiques se
mettent aussi aux couleurs bixente de
l'équipe versaillaise ils soutiennent
avec ferveur le club pour la coupe de
france et c'est l'exemple avec une
boutique d'articles de fête vous y étiez
vous d'ailleurs bixente c'est vous qui
avez filmé pour le reportage est c'est
fait avec célia agathe sango regarder
[Musique]
guirlandes foot mégaphone ou encore
corne de supporters dans cette boutique
spécialisée dans la vente d'articles de
fête le gérant a décoré sa vitrine aux
couleurs du football club d'everton en
une famille de sportifs mes enfants
jouent au fc versailles - bijoux foot en
étant jeune donc avoir une équipe dans
les yvelines
car ça de la coupe de france c'est
génial quoi donc pour nous c'est logique
de les supporter nous parle de
versailles en positif on montre qu'il ya
aussi du sport à versailles donc c'est
génial quoi un soutien légitime pour une
journée spéciale quelques clients sont
également au rendez vous et beaucoup
sont curieux de cette vitrine bien
remplie beaucoup de gens s'arrêtent on a
des gens qui sont venus acheter des
produits faits me gêne un peu de crainte
de supporteurs on sent que bahia quand
même titre engouement au niveau de la
ville qui est aussi sportif du coup pour
l'occasion une fan zone est installé ce
soir place du marché notre dame de quoi
profiter de tous les équipements du
parfait supporter
[Musique]
voilà vous l'avez donc vu un tout le
monde supporte l'équipe verfaillie c'est
justement il me semble qu'on a retrouvé
les cris des supporters qui se sont
produits dans le bus ce matin regarder
l'ambiance allait pas terrible ambiance
du patin
voilà
m
louis saha
honte à toi
chic hôtel
et pour celles et ceux qui n'ont pas pu
faire le déplacement jusqu'à périgueux
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure dans
l'interdît où un écran géant a été
installé place du marché notre dame à
versailles pour suivre ce match et
nicolas adam oui vous êtes sur place
comment ça se passe
ben écoutez le coeur de la cité royale
est en train de bouillir là l'ambiance
est en train de monter il ya du monde de
plus en plus de monde faut savoir que
cette place a été rendue piétonne à
partir de 18 heures et à partir de 18
heures tout le monde à affluer de tous
les côtés de tous les cars et connaissez
est lâchée avec un groupe de jeunes
versailles et bonsoir higuain
ce soir pronostique versailles va
l'emporter ou pas
alors moi je lis plutôt sur sur une
prolongation et des tirs au but le match
va être très fermé dans les 30 premières
minutes ça va se dégager dans les
soixante dixième mais y aura pas de but
il n'y aura pas de but y'aura rend pas
de but ça peut être efficace devant les
cages cela juste sur les prolongations
rester connecter les gars et si bon le
score est important ce soir si si malgré
tout ils perdent ce soir les versailles
et vous serez quand même fier de du de
leur parcours en coupe de france bien
sûr c'est une équipe de n2 faut pas
l'oublier la et bergerac gars ailleurs n
2 maintenant il ya une charte et avoir
compétition entre eux n 2 n 2 ci vont en
demies ce sera incroyable c'est à pas
des scripts comme ça tous les aînés qui
le font mais l'écart des filets c'était
énorme c'est vraiment incroyable on est
fiers d'eux après je pense est une
grande déception c'est versailles perd
ce soir c'est l'équipe de n2 en face à
leur prouver à meilleur n 2 qui sera il
ya et bergerac on les en cubes en commun
voilà voilà le souci voilà justin
l'ambiance est en train de monter on est
à quelques minutes 2 2 lors du début du
match et puis bah écoutez je vais on se
retrouve à la fin du journal à quelques
minutes de l'engagement c'est ça
exactement vous retrouve tout à l'air là
nicolas landry merci beaucoup
ce sera un match serré comme ils ont dit
ces deux grosses défenses par contre les
règles de la coupe de france l'as en
quarts de finale il n'y aura pas de
prolongations c'est penalty directement
en cas de match nul arriver la fin du
temps réglementaire donc à 90 minutes de
jeu merci pour ces précisions bixente
justement important des siens était
d'avoir un écran géant pour suivre pour
ceux en tout cas qui sont ici qui n'ont
malheureusement pas pu faire le
déplacement oui je saigne pour tous fans
de foot c'est royal c'est de vivre un
match dans l'ambiance dans les
conditions comme si on était au stade on
n'a pas tous aussi la chaîne sur
laquelle la rencontre et diffusés ça
permet à ceux qui veulent et qu'ils
n'ont pas l'abonnement par exemple de
voir la rencontre en direct et c'est
aussi une symbolique la ville soutient
club c'est important quand plus pour les
joueurs quand j'ai discuté par exemple
avec le jeune capitaine miles durant de
jeu vinyle m'a parlé tout de suite de la
fan zone il aura des proches là bas
comme d'autres joueurs certainement
merci bixente
[Musique]
il me semble que nous avons françois de
mazières qui serait est disponible avec
nous est-ce que vous m'entendez
[Musique]
oui justin je suis aux côtés de françois
de mazières le maire de personnes qui
vient tout juste d'arriver au stade de
peering alors françois parcours de santé
ou à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi
écoutez c'est une très belle occasion
j'espère que ce sera un très beau match
en tout cas il ya énormément de monde ce
soir on a pu le constater
et puis évidemment les quelques versets
qui sont
leur équipe et vous un petit pronostic
fenêtre sur cette rencontre je n'oserais
pas mais je pense que si nous qu'elles
ont gagné
1 0 comme d'habitude
merci beaucoup françois de mazières et
comme vous l'avez compris à justin les
supporters arrivent le match commence
dans quelques minutes soit en tout cas
bon match avoue amical signé d'euros et
grégory à canal et vous la voulez
entendu même le maire est là pour
soutenir l'équipe
et dans le reste de l'actualité le jeu
de société api city est édité par
l'entreprise versailles et ce cocktail
games et il est en lice pour l'as d'or
du meilleur jeu de l'année il fera face
à carte aventura et seven wonders
architectes dans la catégorie à tout
public le gagnant sera connu au festival
international des jeux de cannes le 24
février mais en quoi consiste ce jeu des
explications de mathilde de franco
le but du jeu construire une ville en
faisant venir des habitants et en les
rendant heureux le jeu de carte happy
city et imaginé par deux japonais
toshiki sato et sa fille héroux repéré
par l'éditeur versailles et cocktail
games api city est aujourd'hui nommé
pour l'as d'or du jeu de l'année dans la
catégorie tout public ce label est
décerné lors du festival international
des jeux de cannes par un jury de neuf
personnes on a de la chance parce que il
ya énormément de jeux qui sont publiés
chaque année avec de la qualité bien sûr
et une création ludique assez
impressionnante c'est vraiment une
reconnaissance du travail bien sûr des
auteurs des éditeurs de la distribuer le
frein de nos distributeurs et la
distribution pour la qualité du jeu même
s'il s'agit de sa neuvième nomination
cocktail games n'a encore jamais
remporté ce prix et espère que cette
année sera la bonne c'est un petit jeu
familial c'est un petit jeu stratégique
et tactique qui est simple d'accès et
simple à prendre en main et à jouer donc
rapide qu'un petit jeu où il faut
construire sa ville
donc pour cela on va construire une
ville en dix cartes donc il faut gérer
ses revenus pour avoir pour acheter des
bâtiments et sur ses bâtiments il y a
des des coeurs ou des habitants parce
que le but du jeu c'est d'avoir la ville
la plus heureuse et pour calculer sur le
bonheur d'une ville fait les petits
coeurs pour les habitants à la fin de la
partie ce qui fait aussi le succès d'
happy city c'est qu'il existe dans une
dizaine de versions différentes à
travers le monde un jeu qui est très
simple qui est
facile à apprendre facile à jouer il n'y
a pas de complicité de langage aussi
c'est relativement simple à traduire les
illustrations beaucoup
fonctionne également
parce qu'ils sont très sympathiques très
très drôle parfois un peu délirante api
city sera face à carte aventura et seven
wonders architectes le gagnant sera
connu le 24 février lors du festival
international des jeux de cannes
et le salon international de
l'agriculture représente un rendez vous
majeur pour les agriculteurs et les
éleveurs du monde entier plusieurs
producteurs libinois seront présents
comme la maison pour le mieux à orgeval
nous faisons à découvrir cette
exploitation familiale dans ce premier
épisode des yvelines au salon de
l'agriculture c'est par mathilde de
francs pour regarder
[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vide 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
installé depuis 1978 à orgeval la maison
folie mais s'étend sur 27 hectares
véritable histoire de famille thomas
élite de l'exploitation de ses parents
en 2005 notre ferme a été créée par les
parents en 1978 ils sont arrivés ici il
y avait seulement
seulement des chaumes de blé ils ont
tous bâtis donc les bâtiments les serres
et ils sont implantés les vergers et
puis développer la culture du maraîchage
sur le plateau d à l'heure la famille y
cultive uniquement des fruits et des
légumes de saison les produits sont
récoltés et vendu le jour même c'est qui
permet d'assurer aux clients leur
fraîcheur donc là l'hiver en fait radis
salades et match et puis on saison bas
tout ce qui est courgettes tomates
aubergines poivrons et donc idem oui il
ya la série de concours actuellement de
la bataille à la bahia de la petite
salade qui sera pour le mois de mars et
shiva landes à préparer la terre on
mettra des congés de début mars autre
point important pour la maison la
pratique d'une agriculture raisonnée
afin de restreindre son impact sur
l'environnement l'entreprise limite ses
apports en engrais et protection
chimique et utilise plutôt des méthodes
naturelles pour lutter contre les
nuisibles nos pratiques culturales sont
basés sur l'agriculture raisonnée donc
on utilise un maximum de lutte
biologique on va par exemple dans les
tunnels introduire des prédateurs pour
contrer les populations de ravageurs
vous voyez là par exemple on est sur un
paillage donc ça nous permet de pas
faire désherbants et puis en même temps
on a une salade qui ne touchent pas le
sol donc du coup on a pas de
développement de maladies donc on arrive
à conduire une bataille a sans aucun
traitement la maison folie se rendra au
salon de l'agriculture pour réaliser une
dégustation de jus maison avec le grand
public et faire connaître sans savoir
faire on sera présent sur deux jours on
fera déguster nos du pommeau on prend on
pourra aussi également vendre notre
production des pommes des conserves
serra de se faire connaître et puis
pourquoi pas de gagner quelques clients
c'est la cinquième fois que
l'exploitation sera au salon de
l'agriculture
c'est une belle vitrine pour nous et
puis c'est important je pense en
ile-de-france de montrer qu'il ya une
vraie production et que le client s'il
souhaite manger local il ya de quoi
faire la maison pologne et propose à la
vente 80 variétés de fruits et légumes
différents
et on est à huit minutes du coup d'envoi
pour le match bergerac et le fc
versailles à bixente un petit mot
peut-être pour l'équipe rapport je vais
vous donner mon petit pronostic
artistique cecelia 1.96 le scénario
idéal forcément ça serait un but rapide
puisqu'en face c'est une bonne défense
donc un but rapide des versaillais et l'
équipe adverse qui pousse tout le long
du match et l'idéal en fin de match
serait d'ajouter un deuxième but par
quelqu'un qui vient du banc qu'on
parlait de christopher iba et
l'attaquant notamment qui est sur le
banc et il ya aussi une nouvelle recrue
johan brun qui arrivé récemment et qui
oscille a marqué ce week-end par exemple
en championnat qui pourrait aussi
marquer pourquoi pas ce soir pour donner
la qualification à son équipe et c'est
un des joueurs arrivés c'est ça il
arrivait tout fraîchement du mercato
très bien et donc du coup on a toutes
nos chances ce soir à bixente 155 ans
donc on allait les équipes sur le papier
comme on disait c'est ça c'est deux
équipes de nationale 2 les deux petits
pouces et ce d'autant que c'est
historique de petits deux clubs de
nationale 2 en quarts de finale ça n'est
jamais arrivé dans l'histoire la coupe
de france on a forcément donc un club de
nationale 2 en demi finales 6 et
versailles tombé et on vous allez suivre
les matchs aller bixente bien sûr la bad
en six minutes de la sortie de plateau
je crois que je vais me ruer sur mon
écran la télévision quand je serai chez
moi ou la radio aussi c'est parti en
tout cas on vous souhaite à tous un bon
match merci beaucoup bixente ners
entités belges à bord a été avec nous
elles journalistes pour tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de refermer ce journal nous
voulions saluer est la mémoire de gerald
de favier qui vient de nous quitter à 81
ans ancien président de télé 78 il a
également oeuvré pendant 22 ans en tant
qu'adjoint au maire à del en cours il
fut vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines durant de
nombreuses années il laisse derrière lui
de multiples réalisations il s'était
retiré de la vie politique en 2018 pour
s'occuper de sa famille à qui nous
adressons toutes nos chaleureuses
pensées
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis pour les moins
sportifs d'entre vous vous pourrez
retrouver le 7 8 sociétés à 18h30 par
mélanie poker heaven saura tout sur télé
[Musique]